[Music]
NASA reportedly is investigating what
may be the first known allegations of a
crime committed from space so what's
going on astronaut and MacLaine's
estranged wife summer worden accuses
McLane of identity theft while McLane
was aboard the International Space
Station McLane strongly denies this
accusation Janet shamlian is at NASA's
Johnson Space Center in Houston so Janet
what do we know about these two
allegations very juicy this is an
unusual one gale good morning summer
warden says she became suspicious when
an mclean new details about her finances
that she herself hadn't shared so when
she asked the bank to check the account
logins that's when she says she knew
some of them were from space it has been
incredibly terrorizing in the midst of a
messy divorce and custody battle over
her six-year-old son summer warden says
an McLain improperly logged on to
wardens personal bank account while
working aboard the International Space
Station we do have a joint account but
what she did is use my personal login
credentials to log in and look at all of
my financial products and even a new
account that I had just set up warden is
a former Air Force intelligence officer
she had her son before she met and
married McLane warden and her family say
they filed complaints against McLane
with NASA's Office of the Inspector
General and the Federal Trade Commission
in a statement on her Twitter page
McLain denied wrongdoing writing there's
unequivocally no truth to these claims
we've been going through a painful
personal separation we're not up here
visiting space we're up here living in
space before the allegations McLain had
spent 204 days in space to heckuva
heckuva duration for her first flight
returning to Earth in late June a
lieutenant colonel in the Army she
served in Iraq and joined NASA in 2013
McLane made headlines earlier this year
when she was slated to be part of NASA's
first all-female spacewalk later
scrubbed because there weren't enough
spacesuits
to fit the women just last week Stars
and Stripes reported McLain was on
nasa's shortlist to become the first
woman on the moon by 2024
no word on whether that's in jeopardy I
really love being up here in space I
really love living here and working here
and I think if I could have my friends
and family visit I might just stay
forever
NASA wouldn't comment but did say that
Ann McLain is one of its top astronauts
and that she did a great job on her
recent mission her attorney is calling
the accusations an avalanche of Lies and
misstatements but the New York Times is
reporting that McLain has admitted
accessing the account while in space but
saying that she did it only to take a
look at their still entangled finances
adrianna Janet thank you it already is
out of this world it's just so messy and
it just shows you know astronauts you
know have people - I would think that
both of them feel regret that this is
all happening on such a public stage
because at the end of the days you point
out it's a little boy involved in this
case and that's what we can't lose sight
of that it is sad well thank you Janet
for that report